alors comment sortir de la crise qui
oppose la biélorussie et la pologne
faut-il s'inquiéter de cette situation
quel rôle l'europe ou encore la russie
peuvent jouer c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison à vos côtés philippe
millet et sénateurs l ère des
deux-sèvres porte parole de valérie
pécresse bonsoir philippe rouyer merci
d'être avec nous et on aurait dû être on
va pas s'en cacher avec aurélien tâche
et un député du val d'oise au président
les nouveaux démocrates qui nous donne
pas de nouvelles peut-être trovati de
surgir pendant ce décryptage ce soir
velimir poutine emmanuel macron d'accord
pour une désescalade dans cette crise
migratoire c'est ce que nous annonce ce
soir que le blanchemaison l'elysée ça
veut dire qu'on est peut-être parti pour
cette sortie de crise tant espéré si on
cherche à résoudre le problème
pratiquement et pas avec des grands
principes c'est faisable il faut tout
d'abord à sécher les flux d'arrivée de
migrants et c'est en cours parce qu'on a
débusqué les réseaux mafieux qui au
proche-orient proposer des forfaits avec
un aller simple pour minsk une nuit
d'hôtel et l'adresse d'un passeur pour
aller jusqu'à la frontière de la pologne
ou de houe de la lituanie et donc les
compagnies aériennes qui ont prêté la
main les hôtels qu'ils étaient dans le
circuit sont tous sous sanction ce soir
et je pense que les ambassades des pays
occidentaux des pays en tout cas
européens et les représentants de la
commission font leur travail dans ces
pays par conséquent le flux d'arrivée
est en train de se tarir alors
maintenant reste à question évidemment
humanitaire et qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
les huit à dix mille qui sont là coincés
à la frontière biélorusse et bien sûr
refoulés par les polonais moi je serais
tenté de dire mais ça n'est pas
évidemment une solution humanitaire
puisqu'ils ont été amenés là avec
manifestement la complicité de ceux
qu'on délivrer les visas avec le forfait
il y avait le billet d'avion y avait
aussi un visa eh bien c'est ce qu'ils
ont délivré le visa c'est à dire le
président biélorusse qui devrait payer
le billet de retour pour les renvoyer
d'où ils viennent mais bien sûr il ya
des considérations humanitaires et à des
enfants il ya des familles et des
malades et il faut les traiter et pour
ça il faut sans doute trouver une
solution ce que je regrette un peu c'est
que la pologne refuse systématiquement
l'aide des agences européennes et elle
se pose aujourd'hui frontex par exemple
d'autres agences humanitaires alors il
faudrait peut-être demander à l'onu
puisque
una texte a été voté jeudi dernier qui
condamne cette action de 2 d'utilisation
des migrants comme arme de
déstabilisation de deux pays voisins et
faire venir des agences humanitaires de
l'onu peut-être aussi l'union européenne
peut-elle en effet faire un geste mais
dans l'immédiat en effet la pologne
refuse que ces migrants qui sont arrivés
là de façon frauduleuse puisse entrer
sur le territoire polonais
fille de mouiller pour revenir on va
évidemment elle est allée plus loin dans
ce qu'on doit la manière de se comporter
avec ces migrants faut-il notamment les
accueillir en europe en france mais sur
cette déclaration de la soirée qui a son
importance ingénieurs poutine qui était
très sollicité dans cette affaire
emmanuel macron d'accord pour une
désescalade
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
aujourd'hui clairement il fallait comme
d'ailleurs l'a suggéré je crois notre
poulain valérie pécresse il faut parler
à la russie dans cette affaire la russie
a un rôle a clairement joué oui oui
d'une façon générale on voit bien que la
vidéo aussi la russie voudrait là sont
particulières pas toujours des relations
je dirais positive mais en tous les cas
les liens sont forts et donc je crois
que la russie fait partie des
intermédiaires avec l on doit pouvoir
discuter pour trouver cette solution et
on voit qu'à première vue c'est
l'initiative a été portée par le
gouvernement mais ce sujet des ronds
l'idée d'une façon globale dans toute
cette région du monde il faut à mener
avant un relais avec la russie avec
aussi cette notion de rapport de force
et de respect de l'union européenne
planche maison ce soir autre information
un gala merkel qui parle apparemment
avec monsieur loukachenko
peut-on imaginer de cette conversation
petit coup de pression on voit quand
même que ça a porté ses fruits tout au
long de l'après midi le président
biélorusse a montré des signes en tout
cas de bonne volonté on n'est pas obligé
de le croire mais je pense qu'il a
constaté que son opération avait échoué
et maintenant il faut en effet résorber
l'opération en limitant les dégâts pour
lui aussi parce que en effet le flux des
réfugiés maintenant à sécher il y en a
pas de nouveaux qui arrivent puisque
toutes les compagnes de faits réels ont
bien compris qu'elle ne pouvait pas
continuer ce petit jeu que monsieur
erdogan que le gouvernement irakien ont
interdit ce genre de transfert de
transport aujourd'hui par conséquent je
pense que madame merkel a dû dire à
monsieur le coach échos que en effet il
fallait qu'ils l'aident à une solution
humanitaire probablement qu'ils prennent
chez lui un certain nombre de ces
réfugiés puisqu'il avait fait venir chez
lui il ya aussi des hôpitaux à minsk
bien sûr ce n'est pas la destination
finale des migrants et il faudra
probablement que l'union européenne
fasse aussi un effort mais il n'y a pas
de raison que l'union européenne ouvre
aujourd'hui ses portes à ces migrants
qui sont arrivés là pour la déstabiliser
par la volonté de monsieur loukachenko
et des réseaux mafieux qui étaient sur
place et qu'acheminer les migrants alors
rien en finance soyez aux finances alors
évidemment ces questions migratoires
sont clairement bien relancé en plein
débat de la présidentielle l'urgence
c'est d'accueillir ces réfugiés a dit ce
matin par exemple gagné jadot le
candidat europe ecologie les verts vous
chez melick techno on n'est pas du tout
dans cette position c'est vrai que c'est
un sujet important parce que c'est un
sujet d'inquiétude des français de façon
générale la politique migratoire en même
temps on a du coeur lorsqu'on voit ces
images de familles qui souffrent on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui il faut trouver des
sources agit peut-être d'une centaine de
migrants apprennent par pays si / mais
l'idée c'est que on a on doit avoir une
position politique très claire a à la
fois je pense qu'il faut trouver des
moyens d'urgence pour venir en aide de
façon humanitaire aux migrants que nous
voyons en images on a vu il faut trouver
des solutions et là non plus empreinte
peut intervenir notamment peut-être en
relais avec les autorités locales oui il
faut trouver des solutions pardonnez moi
enfin il
ya d'abord une urgence pour que ces gens
qui puissent les quelques jours qui
passent ici avant de la solution
politique qu'on puisse venir en aide en
complément il faut être très clair très
ferme il faut que l'union européenne ait
une politique claire de fermeté on ne
peut pas accueillir les migrants parce
que sauron dans cette démarche-là servir
comme abandonné et bien finalement
l'initiative la venue de russie a été
favorable on voit bien qu on est sur un
jeu de déstabilisation politique doit
est donc aujourd'hui il faut une ligne
politique sur lequel est bien on est une
vraie capacité de gérer avec une vraie
politique migratoire claire nette juste
mais on peut pas répondre comme ça
ouvrir les frontières parce que c'est
une déstabilisation et surtout c'est
donner raison à tous ces réseaux mafieux
parce que s'il ya deux sujets c'est une
politique migratoire claire et un vrai
combat partout dans le monde ces réseaux
mafieux pour lequel égal il faut qu'on
mobilise des moyens parce que sans
détruisant ces réseaux que nous aurons
une vraie possibilité imaginez on ouvre
les frontières ça veut dire qu'à un
moment donné on donne du grain à moudre
à ses réseaux pour perdurer en tout cas
la pologne elle ne compte pas les ouvrir
ses frontières l annonce ce soir là la
construction d'un mur ça ça fait grincer
des dents ursula von der leyen qui a
d'ores et nous dit d'ores et déjà dit
qu'elle ne voulait pas payer c'est là
qu'on voit un petit peu les
contradictions peut-être entre l'europe
administratives et les différents pays
notamment en pleine période électorale
qui ne veulent pas entendre parler
d'immigration le mur c'est la guerre
froide et la pologne en effet veut
ressusciter la guerre froide est le
symbole de la guerre froide c'est en
effet le mur alors bien sûr le mur de
berlin avait une autre finalité c'était
d'empêcher les gens de sortir
d'allemagne de l'est là il s'agit de se
protéger de l'afflux des migrants sur le
territoire polonais il ya d'autres murs
dans le monde et en a entre la corée du
nord et la corée du sud
en a aussi à jérusalem pour se protéger
d'éventuels terroristes qui viendrait de
l'autre côté au mexique au mexique pour
se protéger mais ça ne marche pas et au
mexique sans nez on en a l'exemple
puisque en quatre ans le préférant trump
a été dans l'incapacité de faire un mur
qu'ils aient une quelconque efficacité
donc c'est un symbole pour la pologne
qui ne veut pas des agences
européennes communautaire sur son sol
mais qui veut que l'otan lui affirme sa
solidarité totale et c'est ça que vous
la pologne elle veut ressusciter la
guerre froide et elle considère que
l'otan doit confirmer qu il la soutient
et qu'il est prêt à intervenir au besoin
sur cette frontière c'est pas exactement
la position des autres états membres de
l'union européenne et par conséquent en
effet les pays comme la lituanie qui est
qu'ils sont aussi menacés par les mêmes
migrants accepte l'action des agences
européennes ils ont un comportement
normalement européen frontex et les
autres agences interviennent en lituanie
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
n'interviendraient pas en pologne il
faut en tout cas ouvrir des couloirs
humanitaires en effet pour soigner là où
ils sont les gens qui sont malades les
femmes et les enfants
parce que l'on a on sait tous que ces
migrants ne veulent pas nécessairement
rester en pologne qui iront dans
d'autres pays notamment l'allemagne voir
la france donc d'une certaine manière
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ce mur se
muera mahdavi c'est à c'est un symbole
du mauvais fonctionnement de frontex on
voit qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
difficultés c'est à dire que de nouveaux
nous comme nous n'avons pas une
politique claire à l'échelle de l'union
européenne
on est dans une fosse au des piles les
situations changent les moyens de
frontex sont pas suffisants avait quand
même un paradoxe le siège de frontex est
et en pollen donc on pourrait comme se
poser des questions donc on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui la polenta quête de sa
politique à une stratégie aussi propre
et à partir de là le traduit par le mur
mais qui est plus un symbole on sait
très bien que les murs ne fonctionne pas
mais en tous les cas c'est un symbole
qui montre pour moi que l'union
européenne doit revoir sa politique
migratoire et sa position notamment
vis-à-vis de des disciplines elle est un
peu trop tendance à la bouder les hyènes
oui je pense que elle est à la fois à
mon avis un peu déconnecté quand même
des réalités de terrain parce que
lorsque on voit ce qui se passe dans les
zones et lorsqu'on va dans les pays d'où
partent les migrants convoi le système
de vente de rachat va tout le système
mafieux qui va aujourd'hui qui s'est
généralisé eh bien on se rend bien
compte que c'est là qu'il faut agir et
que l'histoire du mur c'est qu'une
conséquence au bout de la chaîne et
c'est là qu'il faut agir et tant qu'on
n'aura pas les vrais moyens eh bien on
sera toujours dans une déstabilisation
et donc ça se traduit bas la pologne à
cette façon de réagir hamalawy trop
radical mais en parallèle et bien il n'y
a pas de solution qui est pour tes
niveau européen ça veut dire que vous
avez encore peur qu emmanuel macron vous
piquent vos idées chez les républicains
quand il va prendre la présidence
tournante de l'union européenne elle va
montrer justement sa fermeté qui va
peut-être lui faire engranger quelques
petites voies côté résidentiel c'est au
moins les six derniers mois de son
mandat il peut réellement avoir une
vraie position une vraie voix qui porte
au niveau européen dans sa révolution
mais un peu tard dans le quinquennat
mais c'est vrai que cette présidence de
l'union européenne emmanuel macron a un
vrai rôle à jouer sur cette question
plus que j'avais dans ce contexte de
crise avec
biélorussie pologne il a un rôle à jouer
mais il faut un qui peut être prudent
parce que depuis le traité de lisbonne
le conseil retient n'est plus présidé
par le président ou le premier ministre
du pays qui exerce sa prescience il est
présidé par
l'ancien premier ministre belge pour une
période de deux ans et demi renouvelable
et il en est de même au niveau les mises
affaires étrangères monsieur borel
président le conseil des ministres des
affaires étrangères par conséquent bien
sûr la présidence peut prendre des
initiatives mais elle doit les prendre
sous forme de conseil informel tous les
conseils informelle sans préciser à
bruxelles par monsieur michel bien sûr
il tient compte de ce que lui donne
comme comme comme une suggestion la
présidence tournante et en l'occurrence
la france mais ça ne sera pas très
facile en plus il faut évidemment quand
on est à la présidence tournante tenir
compte de l'avis les 26 autres
il faut que le secrétaire d'état en
charge des affaires européennes passe
son temps à tourner autour des 26 autres
pour savoir exactement sur chaque point
quelle est la position des uns et des
autres car ils ne supportent plus on
arrive avec une position
franco-allemande et que l'on dise voilà
quelle est la position il faut adopter
avant de refermer ce décryptage voulez
vous faire réagir vous avez peut-être
entendu tout à l'heure le témoignage de
nos reporters qui ont été arrêtés gardez
en garde à vue de longues heures on a
entendu l'avocat des droits de l'homme
qui s'en émouvait pour des questions
tout simplement juridique notre
sentiment sur cette affaire j'ai aussi
le même sentiment vis-à-vis de la
procédure sir qu'ils ont été arrêtés un
jugement rapide sont capacité de se
défendre donc sur la procédure c'est
clairement un hacker temps et ça renvoie
quand même pas mal de questions dont la
capacité a enfin l'expression de la
démocratie en pologne et l'évolution qui
est le tournant qui est pris et en même
temps ben voilà il ya aussi des zones de
deux îles et ils ont décidé à voir des
zones dans lesquelles il n'y avait pas
de possibilité image
complètement parce que c'est une belle
la transparence mais c'est une culture
particulière voilà c'est pas notre
culture voilà donc le forcément il ya
des réactions politiques mais je crois
que c'est un vrai sujet que justement
pour lequel on pourrait entendre du
gouvernement sur la capacité à apporter
un message démocratie à l'échelle de
l'europe est au coeur d'enjeux maison
rapidement également mais là en plein
illustration de cette problématique à
primauté du droit polonais sur le droit
européen car étant voire du renard la
première c'est que c'est pas une bonne
idée d'arrêter les journalistes où que
ce soit partout dans le monde et je dis
bien partout dans le monde deuxièmement
en effet lorsqu'elle est conflit il ya
notamment yann ya souvent des zones de
guerre qui sont qui reçoivent un statut
juridique parfois particuliers
d'exclusion les journalistes et bien sûr
les journées sont leur métier ils y vont
quand même parce que c'est leur métier
de savoir ce qui s'y passe ils prennent
évidemment des risques et la aux
journalistes ont pris des risques ils
ont malheureusement été arrêtés ils ont
été en fait maltraiter puisqu'en effet
ils n'ont pas eu le concours d'un avocat
ce qui est parfaitement inadmissible
merci beaucoup à tous des deux clubs en
maison philippe d'avoir été avec nous et
donc olivier finalement rien tâche elle
ne nous a pas rejoint on le salue s'il
nous entend merci à vous deux en tout
cas